if you think Maxwell's equations
describe all of electromagnetism that
you're missing half the picture this
episode was made possible by generous
supporters on patreon
hey crazies who spent the better part of
the 1800s trying to figure out how
electromagnetism worked to the timeline
in 1820
we got amperes law in 1831 we got
Faraday's law in 1835 we got Gauss's law
in 1861 Maxwell added some stuff and
finally in 1885 Heaviside wrote out all
four than the form we know today
they're called the Maxwell Heaviside
equations and they govern the behavior
and appearance of electric and magnetic
fields but I spent the entire last video
visualizing those four laws this video
is about the fifth law wait what fifth
law the Lorentz force law it tells us
what those fields do they exert forces
see things like magnets and charges can
exert forces on each other over a
distance that kind of seems like magic
which is a problem these two fields are
a way for us to avoid that problem they
act kind of like a middleman or
intermediary one charge creates a field
and it's that field that actually exerts
a force on the other charge the whole
purpose of those fields is to explain
force at a distance but the Maxwell
Heaviside equations only tell us how
fields are made it's the Lorentz force
law that shows us how those fields
affect things they each only tell half
the story
you can't understand electromagnetism
without all five of them and as it turns
out those don't even make complete sense
without special relativity just like the
field comes in two parts electric and
magnetic the force comes in two parts an
electric force caused by the electric
field and a magnetic force caused by the
magnetic field this velocity is going to
be the source of our troubles we've
known since the time of Galileo that
motion is relative I demonstrated this a
long time ago with the tennis ball in a
car actually that reminds me
ever happen to chauffeur Club
[Music]
oh well he'll turn up eventually anyway
if this force has a velocity in it that
means it's also relative to the observer
which is fine most of the time but in
certain circumstances it could become an
issue let's take a look at one of those
circumstances full disclosure I didn't
come up with this example myself
it's from the Fineman lectures link in
the doobly-doo I also did a video on it
a long time ago which was funny but not
very informative I can do better say
we've got a conducting wire made of
loosely bound electrons held in place by
some positive bits
yes it's technically more complicated
than that but it's good enough for today
the wire is electrically neutral there
are just as many positive charges as
there are negative charges so Gauss's
law tells us there's no electric field
but let's say somewhere down the line we
hook up a battery that gets the
electrons moving the wire is still
electrically neutral so no electric
field
however we know from amperes law that
around any moving charge will find a
magnetic field this wire has a magnetic
field that wraps around it now that
we've got a field we should be able to
exert a force on something in this case
it's a magnetic field so we should get a
magnetic force it'll be exerted on
anything that has a charge and is moving
shrink-ray time let's say this squirrel
is positively charged and moving to the
right at the same pace as the electrons
we've got a charge in motion inside a
magnetic field that means there's a
magnetic force the squirrel is repelled
from the wire no problem so far
everything is fine and dandy until we
switch points of view this is what we
might call the lab frame it's the point
of view of everyone in my lab who has
their feet firmly on the ground but what
if I have a clone on a treadmill moving
along with a squirrel instead of this
he'll see something more like this which
we'll call the clone frame there's a
stationary squirrel a bunch of
stationary electrons and some positive
bits moving to the left those
positive bits will create the same
magnetic field but the squirrel isn't
moving which means there's no magnetic
force um without a force how does the
squirrel get repelled it can't isn't
that a problem oh yes most definitely
this example breaks electromagnetism
forces may be relative but events are
not these are both equally valid points
of view if the squirrel is repelled in
one of them it must be repelled in the
other that can happen a slightly
different way or even for a different
reason but it must happen for all points
of view thankfully Einstein's special
relativity can fix this problem it's
really good at handling shifts in point
of view like this according to the model
there are only a few things that stay
the same under these shifts charge is
one of them everything else is relative
that means they change under these
shifts the one will be taking advantage
of today is length as you shift from one
point of view to another the lengths of
objects can change and so can the
distance between them they don't just
appear - they actually do like for real
how much they change depends on how much
your point of view has shifted the shift
here isn't very big but it's still
enough to fix our problem I'll
exaggerate everything for the rest of
the videos so you can see what's
happening in the lab frame the squirrel
is moving so it's contracted along that
direction everything in the wire is fine
it happens to be neutral in this frame
just like before the magnetic field
around the wire exerts a magnetic force
on the squirrel repelling it away in the
clone frame things look a little
different the squirrel and electrons are
stationary so they're not contracted
anymore now that the positive bits are
moving they are contracted that means
this part of the wire has a net charge
density charge may be invariant but
space is not charged density is the
amount of charge divided by the space
set charge occupies in our case we're
measuring that space as a distance the
electrons have expanded and the positive
bits have contracted which means they
occupy a different amount of space their
density has changed each spot along the
wire has a net positive charge
according to Gauss's law that means
there's an electric field if there's an
electric field the Lorentz law tells us
there's an electric force bingo bango
we've got a force in the clone frame the
squirrel still repels from the wire it's
just due to an electric force instead of
a magnetic force Oh crisis averted
thanks Einstein like I said though the
total amount of charge is still
invariant if you look at the whole
circuit you can see what's really
happening while we have a net positive
charge near the squirrel the segment
farther away has a net negative charge
the charge has just redistributed the
point is special relativity fixes our
problem by making the following
statement the magnetic force in one
frame of reference could easily be an
electric force in another or some
combination of them in a third frame we
can show this in the Lorentz force law
by pulling out the charge you might even
call this thing here the electromagnetic
field actually that's got me thinking
about something if you can say this
about electric and magnetic force you
should also be able to say it about
electric and magnetic fields rather than
treating these as two separate things we
should be able to treat them as one
thing but if we want to do that vectors
aren't gonna cut it
we need tensors the electromagnetic
field tensor to be specific it's
straight out of special relativity for
rows and four columns because there are
four dimensions in space-time it
represents the electromagnetic field as
a field of tensors one tensor at every
point in space in every moment in time
it grew the electric and magnetic fields
together in just the right way so the
Lorentz force law still works out the
same we even get electrical power as a
bonus so how does special relativity fix
electromagnetism by allowing
measurements to change between points of
view in the lab frame the moving
electrons use the magnetic field to
exert a magnetic force on a squirrel in
the clone frame the electrons expanded
and the positive is contracted this left
the wire charged allowing it to exert an
electric force instead the squirrel was
repelled by the wire in both frames
sometimes magnetism is just electricity
in a different frame of reference so
hopefully this version of the video
makes a lot more sense let me know in
the comments if it helped thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and it's till next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
I asked you whether or not I should make
more videos visualizing equations and
the vote was a landslide most of you
seemed to really like it I guess I have
a new type of video I can make sometimes
thinking Baby Einstein's field equations
yeah that'll be fun anyway thanks for
watching
[Music]